Carmen Lopez can only imagine what the sea
looks like.
But that hasn't stopped the 21 year old Spaniard
from riding the surf.
I feel free and relaxed.
I don't have any concerns and it's just me
and the wave.
Coach Lucas Garcia guides Carmen by whistled
signals.
He's trained her to compete at the World Adaptive
Surfing Championship.
No one had ever thought that blind people
could surf.
And suddenly we find Carmen, who can surf.
She needs some extra help in the water compared
to other adapted sports, but at the end when
someone wants something, they can break the
limits and everyone can surf.
Carmen was born with congenital glaucoma,
and lost her vision completely when she was
a child.
She wants to encourage others with physical
challenges to push past their limits.
To keep showing day by day and with everything
that I do on this, that if you want something
you can get it.
And if you have or do not have a disability,
the important thing is to do what you like
the most.
And that people put their own barriers up,
no one else puts them there.
Carmen has also learned figure-skating and
horseback riding.
With her bold attitude, the sea's the limit.